comment empêcher la facture
d'électricité des espagnols de flamber
c'est devenu le problème majeur du
gouvernement de pedro sanchez à madrid
depuis plusieurs mois les facture
s'envole atteignant des montants jamais
vu une situation qui met en difficulté
aussi bien des ménages que l'industrie
du pays est les précisions de clémentine
laurent
les prix de l'électricité flambe en
espagne depuis plusieurs mois déjà en
juillet août et septembre dernier les
tarifs étaient déjà très élevé mais la
semaine dernière ils ont battu un
nouveau record lundi le prix du
mégawattheure a atteint les 100 86 euros
et 46 centimes en fait il a été presque
multiplié par six en un an c'est du
jamais vu alors il existe plusieurs
raisons à cette augmentation des prix de
l'électricité ici tout d'abord on
assiste dans le monde à une explosion
des prix des matières premières liées à
l'énergie par exemple le pétrole le
charbon ou encore le gade et l'espagne
est particulièrement touchée mais il ya
aussi les droits d'émissions de dioxyde
de carbone dont les prix est en pleine
augmentation le prix de la tonne de co2
ne cesse de croître depuis un an et
enfin il ya aussi la vague de chaleur
qui a touché le pays en juillet alors
pour les consommateurs avec des prix
aussi élevés il faut faire preuve
d'organisation
je vous propose d'écouter les réactions
des barcelonais ils exagèrent vraiment
c'est de plus en plus cher à la fin les
gens ne pourront plus payer
l'électricité
on bat chaque jour des records
historiques en terme de prix
je mets le lave vaisselle et la machine
à laver le week end en heures creuses et
les autres jours si ce n'est pas urgent
je ne les utilise pas
cette flambée des prix de l'électricité
impact aussi les entreprises certaines
ont même dû prendre des mesures
drastiques comme l'arrêt de leur
production durant plusieurs jours car
les coûts sont devenus trop élevés le
gouvernement espagnol a approuvé un plan
pour contenir l'augmentation des tarifs
mais madrid discute également avec
l'union européenne pour trouver une
solution plus globale